you
the SE 2d grid shell is an open-air
pavilion that was built as an extension
of the a CTD library so it's an open-air
structure that doubles as as work space
for the library but it also serves a
second purpose of posting a CTD events
get-togethers and dinners so the project
actually started as a student workshop
the students worked in teams for two
weeks came up with some design proposals
and it was society that one team's idea
of doing a grid shelf was innovative and
interesting and so after that we worked
for about nine months on the design of
this place there were indeed some
significant challenges along the way one
of them which was making sure that
everything fits at the end we had
basically just only one construction
drawing which was sort of a numeric map
that indicated where each piece goes the
contractors simply followed that map and
pieced the whole ritual together like a
puzzle
I think personally that one of the
interesting things about the grid shell
is that it's entirely made in Singapore
it was a pretty major production process
that involved over a hundred people in
various roles we tried to wrap that
whole geometrical solution to the
software but others can use it really
resulted a new way of building
structures these projects always
teamwork and you can't do it alone
we had very nice relationship with our
engineers our client plus fabricators
builders I think the president Design
Award is a wonderful annual celebration
of design in Singapore it points out
things that are already well-known and
highly celebrated and other times it
puts the spotlight on projects that
people don't know very much about but by
giving an award to such project and
draws a lot more people to pay attention
to them I think it's also important for
designers to pick what they individually
are really good at and really push
themselves in becoming even better at
that this is the SE TD great shelf
design of the air
you